Vox is trying to replace sexist violence
for domestic violence.
This,
that seems like an unimportant detail of language,
is crucial.
The concepts and words we use
have the power to build mental Marks.
Saying anti-abortionist is not the same as saying pro-life.
Both refer to the same thing,
but from completely different points of view.
It depends on the word you use
it is already possible to glimpse your position in the debate.
Who can fix the words
has half won the debate.
Returning to the topic,
domestic violence exists and is real.
It is any type of violence that occurs
within the framework of a family,
between cousins,
grandchildren and,
between uncle and,
between daughter and mother.
There are endless combinations.
What defines this type of violence is
only the link between its members,
while male violence
is something completely different.
First, because
does not have to occur in the family environment.
You may suffer machismo at work,
with your friends,
on the street,
with a corpse.
To think that male violence
only your partner or ex-partner may exercise it
is not to understand machismo and,
and it's kind of the vision I had 50 years ago,
60 years,
two.
Machismo
is a type of violence that women suffer.
and it is something that has its history and origins.
We cannot forget history.
Less than 100 years ago
that women could not vote because we were not
Considered citizens
Abascal that we could not vote.
Is it domestic violence or is it something else?
Attempting to eliminate the concept of machismo
is something thought out and studied,
has a whole strategy behind it and it's no coincidence.
The extreme right denies machismo,
show us this with these details.
Do not use consciously
the concept of gender violence
and exchange it for domestic violence
is wrong and ideological.
This is just one detail
and the consequences of this
we will begin to see it in all municipalities
where the extreme right has entered